at six o'clock this morning police
encountered a male with a knife in the
area of leicester square
two officers have been stabbed
and are currently being treated in
hospital
we are being told a taser was deployed
and a man was arrested on suspicion of
grievous bodily harm and assaulting an
emergency worker he was taken to a
hospital for treatment where he remains
at this time we're told enquiries into
the circumstances surrounding the
incident are ongoing two police officers
stabbed
in leicester square at six o'clock this
morning a couple of hours or so ago uh
the mayor of london street khan
is with us um to talk of course about uh
the plans for the queen's funeral but mr
mayor perhaps you could reflect on that
first of all um so many police officers
in london at the moment always have to
be on guard
well i've spoken to the commissioner
about the awful stabbing of two of our
officers it's a reminder
of the risks all our officers across the
country take every day
when they put on their uh uniform it's a
live investigation so i shouldn't talk
about the the incident but i'm sure i
speak for you and you all our viewers
your viewers when i say that these two
offices are in our thoughts and prayers
hoping they make a swift recovery